[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [FAKE SNORING]
Oh, hey!
Welcome to my living room.
I'm just kidding.
We're still at I/O 2017.
And here I am with
Spence and Nikhil,
and we're going to
talk about Assistant.
Spence, what's going
on in this room?
SPENCE: We have a
living room set up.
You're actually hanging
out in our living room.
We've got a Google Home set up
with a bunch of very cool home
devices.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you can
control all of these devices
with your voice?
SPENCE: Yes, yes I can.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: OK, which ones?
What do you got?
SPENCE: We've got a television,
which is a necessity,
of course.
We have a fan.
We've got a thermostat,
two lights, speakers,
and even an air purifier.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [LAUGHS]
That's awesome.
Can we turn on the fan?
SPENCE: Let's try that.
Hey Google, turn on the
fan in the living room.
GOOGLE HOME: You got it.
Turning the fan on.
SPENCE: Excellent.
It's a little chilly, though.
Hey Google, please
turn off the fan.
GOOGLE HOME: Sure,
turning the fan off.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: [LAUGHS]
That's so much fun.
NIKHIL: So what's
happening over here
is Google Home is
basically connected
to Genie Plugs for the fan,
and it's connected to Honeywell
for the thermostat.
And so it's able to
understand your query,
able to understand what
the user's intent is,
convert it into
a structured form
that we can then communicate
out to Honeywell or Genie
and actually fulfill the action.
So it's going over the cloud.
It's going over Wi-Fi and
actually getting things done.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's very cool.
Let's see, is there anything
else we want to try?
SPENCE: We can do the lights.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Let's do the lights.
SPENCE: How about that?
It's blue right now.
Let's go for--
Hey Google, turn the lights
red in the living room.
GOOGLE HOME: Sure,
changing two lights to red.
SPENCE: That's a mood thing.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Whatever
the party calls for.
SPENCE: It works.
It works.
We also have an air purifier.
We have a TV.
We can basically have some
fun in the living room.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's the
living room of the future.
Wayne, come on over here and
tell me about the developer
angle with all of this stuff.
What are developers
able to interact with?
WAYNE: Well, the nice
thing is at I/O here,
we've announced
the Smart Home API.
So it allows developers to
build their own devices.
And they've got their cloud.
We've got an SDK that allows
it to plug in really easily.
So all of these
device makers were
able to easily integrate
their devices like light bulbs
and thermostats in
with our ecosystem
so it can be controlled easily.
And the nice thing is
that Google Home takes
care of all the speech
recognition, all
the natural language
understanding,
and you just get simple commands
to your light bulbs that
tell you what to do-- turn
it off, change its color,
or whatever.
So it's really easy.
We've got open source
samples that show how
to build a virtual light bulb.
And then you basically
just hook that
into your existing
infrastructure,
and you're good to go.
So it's actually really
simple, and we're
adding new APIs all the time
for different kinds of devices.
So we've got a couple here,
but there's plenty more coming.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Awesome.
Well, hey, let's just hang out
and watch the game, shall we?
WAYNE: Oh, wait a minute.
We've got watch this
video first of you and me.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh,
yeah, let's do that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[LAUGHS]
It's vintage.
[LAUGHTER]